say that
all the time
you know what i'm saying like you get it
but a lot of guys like don't know their
value
because women have been telling them
they ain't [ __ ] from like a young age
but girls use that like innate
protection and their beauty to like
i think put up a smoke screen against a
lot of guys
just like my friend and actually i
wouldn't i wouldn't call her friend but
like girl girl on my girl my
associate
an acquaintance yeah yeah in in college
right like she had a whole smoke screen
up
to get what she wanted
right
and i think a lot of guys like
i just think women take advantage of it
i'm not saying it doesn't go both ways
but i think like women we can see more
like we're like ah i know that trick
because i've done that trick right i've
done that i've done that like nah nah
nah nah women are more emotionally adept
but i think like by and large like men i
think if i had to pick right we do who
picks better of the opposite gender on
their own i think men pick better wives
than women pick husbands do you i would
disagree by and large i think today men
don't play better wives well yeah
because i because it's not to pick from
huh there's all not a lot to pick from
especially but i mean like if we if we
take the stance so we know 80 of
divorces are initiated by the woman how
much of that is because he chose the
wrong kind of woman
do you think
you think 50 of women are the wrong kind
of women as in like for him if she
wasn't going to stay with him long term
because i mean like
because
arguably if you chose you know you've
said it yourself if a girl is a virgin
or has less had been with less than five
sexual partners she's more likely to
have successful marriage but we know
full well most men aren't choosing those
kind of women to marry
so how much of men being divorced by
women is actually because men are making
bad choices in who they choose to marry
i would say it's because women don't
want to get married at the ages that
they would be the best wife
so so
if a girl has in the uk what's the
average age of first marriage i think
it's 20 for women or men women i think
it's 28 31 is it 31
right
it's like men 32 women 31 okay women
don't want to get married when they have
the most to offer as a wife
hmm
did they used to
back in the day yes what do you think's
changed birth control
you get to [ __ ] around for ten years
interesting that's if you look at the
divorce rate and you look at the rate of
women using hormonal birth control
they're like the same you could put a
pop-up i'll send you the chart it is
it's mad
it's like when the divorce rate goes up
it's like the same when women start
using birth control
as in as when a woman gets divorced she
goes on birth control no no like the
rate at which women use birth control it
in
so as as in the 70s yeah i believe it
was the 70s when they when they started
putting when women started taking birth
control yeah at that same time
the divorce rate went up and if you put
the charts next to each other where it's
like the percentage of women on birth
control versus or like the rate of women
taking it was something silly that
basically said
how how many women were taking birth
control right and how many women were
getting like divorced right it was like
the same
okay so they get that there could be a
correlation but it doesn't mean a
causation that's true
but
right all right
yeah look at the charts
um you don't think there's any
because it gives women to the option to
fulfill both mating strategies
i think that's the main thing yeah so so
and i'm sure most before they didn't
yeah because they can they can sleep
with the hot guys in their 20s and then
their 30s they find the dude to take
care of them
but like the problem is most guys
they're not they don't know this
do you think do you think dude from
college has any idea that his girl was
getting screwed in the bathroom i'm
telling you if i showed you the girl
brought her in a room and introduced you
guys to her you would have no idea i
promised to god you would have no idea
maybe that's fair you wouldn't you
wouldn't guess and that's the thing like
guys don't realize like they're the
girl's second choice
i i think
i think there are a few cues i think
yeah if you know what to look for yeah
you have to know what's in it yeah but
you don't if you don't know what to look
for like
the thing is though i think it's funny
because when you
maybe it's less nowadays but i know
in school growing up into teens since my
20s like when you asked girls what they
wanted a lot of them would express
wanting
a relationship someone they care admire
and stuff so they're not expressing that
they
and i think they still do want that
so the whole thing of them you know like
you said using both mating strategies in
the sense of
messing around so she gets the alpha
seed and then getting the beta knee
later on
like
most of the expression comes from
wanting something
with one person not messing with the
fields just trying to get the hot guy
yeah but he's not real
who's no real
the the perfect combination of both but
what i mean is like the so like you're
saying the message actually is that oh
that she can she can have casual sex
with the hot guy and then get the nah
she'll try to lock down the hot guys
just like it's like okay it's like bad
boys can't be locked down
they're for the streets forever you
think future
yeah she'll she'll lock down the alpha
if she can she'll try her best even
maybe get a kid off of him yeah but you
you can't they're for like why would
they
yeah and so it's like do you think do
you think bad boys are for the streets
forever okay okay
for the most part okay i some some do
settle down yeah it's it's true yeah but
i i think
with the marriage laws being how they
are
women being how they are
it's good luck convincing that man to
leave the streets
you can't
it depends i think it depends on um and
i'm saying i'm not i'm not talking about
guys that are like sleep with a lot of
girls i'm talking about the bad boys
give us the difference
um okay
there are guys that just sleep around
because they're young
and then there's like the drug dealers
no every bad boy's a drug dealer no no
you're right or like the
the
i don't know it's just i don't even know
how to describe it but it's like the
futures of the world okay that's the
best way i would describe it is the
futures versus the russell russell
wilson i'm sure you don't think russell
wilson slept around
yeah that's fair yeah like he he
probably did too yeah would you say it's
not like i guess but you can just you
can just tell the difference i don't
know
it's like a man if a man is if he is
living life for his own pleasures and
then if he wants i think if a man wants
to find meaning in life
then i think that's when he chooses to
prioritize building a legacy and then
choosing one woman yeah but i think if
he's just a man who's just i just want
to enjoy
the pleasures that life has to give then
yeah i agree he's a he's one of the
futures of the world
i hear that that makes sense um like
future he i think he's engaged is he
ever
like and he just released a song about
sierra demon like
yeah he's on demon time like yeah i hear
that
um
i'm gonna ask something that i think
some of your viewers would definitely
ask um
do you want to get married i do yeah
how do you as a modern day woman want to
how do you how are you going about
finding a wife school
why school you cut but like who's being
your wife's school who's oh oh you wait
you wait tune in to my channel tune in
to my channel so what you're gonna have
and she's coming i need to meet this